hey guys I'm Ryan Wright we're gonna
check out this video today called exes
cuddle again for the first time in years
how is your boyfriend buzz so my name is
Ben and I was together with Linda for a
couple months I'm doing this just
because I like kind of doing weird
things I I don't know why I'm doing this
I think my ex is great she's great you
know she's so she's really sweet like
I'm Alex and I was dumped heart and my
name is Whitney and I was with my
significant other for six months and I
dumped him so the way she broke up with
me was she said that she just wanted to
be friends I feel like I need to clear
the air a little bit because I think I
was made out to be a villain so I made
this song called let's just be friends
and put it in a music video that I made
on YouTube this freaking music video
about me it was really cathartic
actually to make that video that kind of
rubbed me the wrong way but you know
good for him
I watched it it's kind of catchy I'll be
really doing thank you you're welcome
oh yeah it's like survivor Wednesday's
should I like embrace do you want to
like actually like just do it just do it
I feel like I never did this what we
dated nothing yeah you're right how is
your boyfriend oh he's great this is
gonna be awkward to have him watch sorry
about this I did you do you bought about
what started up nope don't know we
bought over a lightbulb and I wanted it
I wanted a rifle that was aiming for
it's like the blue one outside your
apartment and I wanted it off and you
were like no I like that and I was like
I feel really insecure like why do you
feel insecure and I was like because I
feel like you don't want me here
and we're like you're like I don't wanna
be in relationship and I was like that's
like childish with me if I been you back
then are you still ticklish yeah most
definitely
but I rebounded after you and that was
like a [ __ ] show
did you regret breaking up with me for a
little bit yeah I did like I'd let a
good thing go a compliment for this
lovely gentleman he makes me laugh very
hard and it's babies everywhere I didn't
like the sweater you are in our second
date I was like whatever that's okay I'm
Emily the blue one was just not ready
you're very unique and I have not met
too many people like you it just looks
kind of like pretentious this feels so
good I hate that I'm sort of sorry that
I went down the way did but I'm glad you
got success from your music video you
know one we wouldn't have found two new
people living exactly see it just looks
nice some things aren't just meant to be
yeah you know wasn't as bad as I thought
I would think it was it's kind of nice
so good to reconnect yeah didn't hurt
that was fun it was fine solved that
weird there you go high-five
see we can high-five now they didn't a
high-five out of it and doesn't love my
eyes okay yeah that was to her Oh what's
wrong
why it's just a high-five come on
but be careful Wow there was a lot of
things wrong with that video there's a
lot of tension in that video sure I like
how the first couple were like yeah I
was okay we broke up but we're cool and
then they're the ones who ended yeah and
then the other but that guy just got up
and walked off and then when she said
why they broke up I'm like that guy just
has anger issues and she's just totally
fine she was clowning on him a little
too much though I get from a guy
perspective he wasn't saying anything
like that was the only thing they could
talk about true but I did like the
curly-haired guy and the girl like he's
such a dweeb who probably still has
feelings for her you [ __ ] made him
look like he yeah and she just seems
like a hate to be judging yeah I don't
mind being judgmental I've been in a
bitter mood since I've been stopping
smoking she looks like a [ __ ] a real
[ __ ] she looks like a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
one word yeah she was trying to be
really supportive of me like it's a good
thing you got something out of that
video I really don't want to be here my
thing was like why does she agree to it
like he seemed really hopeful that like
they could be friends again and she was
just like why am I here if she has a
boyfriend now and he has a girlfriend
that's probably that shouldn't be
happening now how much do they pay them
I wonder that's probably why they did it
yeah cuz that just seems so wrong and I
felt so sorry for their spouses
it was entertaining tension was
ridiculous they start off like okay
we've made our peace and as it
progresses it's just like weird but
curly hair dude was like after he was
done he felt like really good at my
[ __ ] endorphins are running yeah but
he seems like he'd be really clingy so I
get why she would want I mean she breaks
up with him after six months and then he
writes her a music video it does a music
video for her it's it's a little bit
obsessive because she was like I kind of
feel sorry yeah but anyway uh yeah
thanks guys for saying that was out
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the Rio rejects
sally has a channel too you can check it
out salamander Sally and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where there's many photos of this but
she's doing this with her spouse and I'm
doing this with my spouse okay
hope you guys are getting jealous
Matthew Lacey hey guys love your channel
Congrats on the 100,000 subscribers
thanks a lot man you know I really
earned my way to here yeah like when I
watch videos and I have to be like that
is so like the amount of hour I put into
this profession is so demanding oh look
at Matthew he has a guitar nice man okay
Matthew listen to me buddy I'm gonna end
this real fast I want you to know that
with that guitar Sally will vouch for
this you can't get [ __ ] up the roof my
friend
[ __ ] [ __ ] buddy buddy
yeah buddy buddy I'm still not over how
we lock early cuddles yeah it's like we
broke a barrier this I don't look at it
as coddling I look at it as like we
hugged and then I fell backwards and we
just kind of stayed there for a little
bit to finish the video I'm gonna shower
again